well you did all the hard like this
oh [__] lately I'm not worried about it
right now
- I got $10 worth the head but when I do
[Laughter]
[Music]
BAM you bad [__] uncle Joey
here re-shift Lisa at doing our thing
setting the air man free [__]
tremendous tonight I told you Monday the
14th we got [__] younger we got
[__] the Stars adaptive empty we got
liquid acid I mean listen it's over
tonight you understand me I don't know
what you would think in or what you
ain't thinking I don't know if you
waiting for Conan or [__] Hiller
shows it's hard be home by the time
we're here [__] stays on there
beautiful you hurt me too Oh
[Music]
look at these [__] pieces a hash I got
tonight
[Music]
you dirty [__] houses the holy
look at this [__] right here we got a
couple different [__] reefers in you
got that are x26 I'm Bobby let me show
you all the pieces this is dirty [__]
percent THC I got the documentation
these guys gonna [__] around there's
been our Vice hitting their leak yup
tell us you got next door D yeah your
turn [__]
please please please
I want a blood test with this oh [__]
here we go
I'm gonna burn this chunk of debt right
here look at the size of this [__]
[Music]
there you go [__] like
professionals look at that rock with
that meteor [__] Armageddon and Bruce
Willis look at that [__] media all
right there little [__] no quarter
let's Eppler we yeah we know
are you [__] kidding me that's my
Goomba Johnson type [__] right there
please executive in charge of making
sure everything gets melt [__]
tremendous I don't know what the [__]
you doin blowtorch is this is it this
would be Irishman doing for 200 company
is gonna get in there Lisa
oh [__] what the [__] are you doing with
your lives [__] the boss not the
ass
you got that [__] look at they
okay it's amazing what we do you can't
even see the hammer that's it
you know settles of the bomb this is
tremendous
building up like a [__] science
experiments is it this is good as
against my brother's this is what
expanding your one's this is where
company you're very [__] smartly it
does expand you you correct you are
correct that means you get nothing
that's a Monday night can you imagine
what happens here the [__] Thursday
[__] look at this look at the
slope coming from this side okay I'll do
another one here like a soldier
[Music]
[Applause]
[__] you know how we do it here you
wanna [__] around with these other
Mickey Mouse [__] either doing
this in that day doing dick
I'm thinkin I thought next level like
this no quarter in hash on a Monday
night what the [__]
what are you do with your life what the
[__] are you doing with your life I'm
saying getting this up real men wear
black body up on the door once these
squares can smell it Brown this month
look at that [__] lean that's real
[__] Egyptian it's from the one-eyed
you what are you gonna do I mean I've
done this before word
look at this [__] beauty right here
man you have a smoke all day get the
party started - UK milligram you came on
the right night if you have a smartphone
thing don't reverse order
we're smoking everything deep until the
murky waters of the other world you got
no corner on there's like being a grin
all over you with the rooms you get the
smoky from other hand a honest I'll buy
you all stay for the next one not gonna
leave it [__] yeah you bad [__]
and you thought it was gonna be a light
night I watch the chance you eat
something else I ain't that type of
party tonight you want to eat yoga go
hang out with somebody else
[Music]
so my opinion it's just dead
that's no quarter yes I see what
beautiful artwork that's what's gone
that's what's missing yeah what happened
was the story was this okay they put
this out man you gotta check out I don't
know before after the singers brother
plant sundial
he always said he sacrificed they sold
their souls exactly what bad bunch of
[__] go
the son's name was correct if you go to
into the outdoor all of my love is for
the Sun that's on Kashmir about the
country of Kashmir I'm not sure what
it's a it's a [__] great champion
[Music]
that
we [__] around here tonight people
you want to [__] around go roller skate
the Sun I'm saying we're taking it to
the next level
[Music]
well timing out John
see start a trivia periscope then you
get high with these beautiful this is it
the pregame is what they do on the
Lord's Day they surround more coverage
and they tell you what the bet with not
the better the devil is I got nobody
I got fairleigh dickenson my buddy Greg
her end is the coach oh [__]
[Music]
are you [__] kidding me though if you
want to join in just put on this [__]
down
I don't know what it's called I was with
the holy I think I don't even know it's
just too much it's too [__] much
listen to the social [__] you get on
iTunes
whatever this is the [__] hour of the
night now because the other side really
kills you will [__] not the song may
is the same and over the hills and far
away [__] you think you're dealing for
Hannah you're staring at me like I owe
you $10 what the [__]
go fatherly look at them look at Lee
[Music]
[__] this hash tip but you take it
actually finish this week it'll take
that will put on the bottom till the
last minute
remember that's the [__] that really
killed Moses last night dog history of
the world was on Jesus Jesus back the
girls
he plays no books plays the [__] to
stand up philosophy the Dom DeLuise he's
at Caesar's Palace [__] classic yep I
love Port au if you [__]
haven't seen history of the world you
don't know what the [__] you're missing
that's real real [__] Mel Brooks
bones and eat their [__] good
they show some risk a [__] man opens up
the line
sexy was invented you know you see a
chick walking a cavewoman you see a
caveman come up there when they have a
rocking dragon and it says you know
homosexuality was invented you see a guy
walking through a jungle that come out
with a break-in a man that plays and
Sally's a good [__] up movie
Richard Pryor was supposed to be the
black guy and they Schaffer them in
there that's why he got so pissed off
the Hollywood both oh yeah pick another
[__] song for you [__] to get
the party started tonight my main man
Ari Shaffir is here this is not
happening is on Tuesday nights right
Tuesday night from Thursday nights 12:30
and then in the morning they released a
video
[Music]
the show I was I was just looking to see
what day came out when I was writing the
description has a 90% up like approval
from Rotten Tomatoes which I like really
no I'm sorry
it's a [__] legendary album right
here this is this is just too [__]
much I don't even know if I should put
it on unless you're shooting everyone at
home but I'm gonna put it on video just
so you see how [__] what music was
really [__] like you should we give
them a break to get the heroin here we
go legendary out oh [__]
[Music]
break on through to the other side Soul
Kitchen the crystal ship 20th Century
Fox Alabama song light my fire
backdoor man I looked at you end of the
night take it as it comes and the end I
would pay the [__] $10 just for the
end you understand me
that's how good music was and whatever
year this funkman came on it so put that
in your [__] hash pipe this called
that [__]
[Music]
I see you
everybody
[Music]
may we go [__]
sau ha k r aut the [__] you think you're
dealing with in I want the fourth grade
spelling fee was until you slay that you
believe Lisa never had salad fathers
he's never had sauerkraut he's never eat
somebody's [__] understand what
that's what's wrong with society break
break break but are you [__] nuts
I'm telling you go rate grandma's [__]
medicine cabinet this don't get this
notion this don't let up on you this
[__] down listen for this [__] are
you [__] kidding me
we have to turn the lights out turn the
lights on we show these moments closes
though
[Music]
guess about five minutes my system
another 125 volt woodshed put us at 8:25
for the world times would take and here
we go
[Music]
yeah why do seven times you wanna do
applause what the [__]
the same yesterday if we - wait the
corner put you right we need to be
really really fellow we needs another
[__] edible don't
[Music]
if they can't do that they really a
magician [__]
[Laughter]
that's death right there there you go
listen you can take all your [__]
edibles you see that [__] walking 200
but what's what's seven is two yeah [__]
yeah let's go for my [__] dog let's
break on record are we see how he's
gonna do another 200 will let him lose
it to [__] crutches our fallenness
telegrams who's gonna stop
[Music]
oh [__]
this is certainly Sam you fella this is
Apocalypse Now this is as good as
[__] it gets but it will not be this
one is the scary [__] this is this is
this is we might even hit that [__]
thing a little liquid acid listen to
this backwards the doors back doors you
[__] spirit that I was playing that's
how people do it and you see here the
Titanic messages that [__] lead please
don't go to subway no more there's one
of the greatest songs of all time in my
world the end by the doors
I'm telling we should do 900 milligrams
to sing this song
[Music]
[Laughter]
nobody
[Music]
you think I know she doesn't know that
[__] problem that's a dad he effected
that [__] poof [__] every time
we think it dealing with you huh you're
at home we having a good time you know I
love you [__] if you got the
doors put them on I don't know what you
got at home if you got to whatever as
long as you get your head together get
your notebook look out the window don't
jump just look at us here we go kick
this [__]
[Music]
this is [__] brilliant man he's doing
poetry
[Music]
what you say you wanna stop another poll
you know what
[Music]
[Laughter]
Joey is getting deep we gotta smoke
another bowl that's what I was gonna say
no unless you people say nothing people
get mad at you oh [__] [__] you're
Chelios really I love doing that I'll do
that to the damn [__] dead here which
might be tonight we might break our own
record we got my 13 stars think Jake
dinner's on the [__] phone
get get us on the phone telling you
right now we'll bring it on consume
tonight on a Monday night cuz there's a
wreck of a Friday night Saturday night
well hope take you down a dark street on
a Monday night the church here we go
baby
[Music]
[Laughter]
right the snake [__] right that
[__] anybody but your re still
alive this battle [__] we're going
deep till I got sons
[Music]
man
oh [__] do television would be a [__]
up day here you are with re the flying
jeweled Apple Joey listen to the [__]
doors now we're gonna start after the
song in the West is the best that's why
I'm over here smoking [__] bazookas
with my friends listen to these [__]
drums here please about to have a
nervous break
[Music]
we got [__] paper tubes
we even got this if you want to get to
the next level and this here is from
Eureka
they got vapor syringes you understand
me you put the needle right here and you
put it right in your [__] forehead
and you shoot the TAC right to your
[__] brain you hide for 1215 hours
let's say you got you go to Europe
whatever the [__] no you can't stick
this in your skin you dumb [__] see this
is a little oil here to put on [__]
joints pipes if you got a PUD you follow
me but you know what whatever you want
to do this Monday night March 14th you
gotta ask yourself
[Music]
he went to the room with systole
gotta [__] believe that somebody could
do something like this this is one
reason the bushes and he's about to
sneak up to kill the cow in half
[Music]
right Jesus right
Li's having a nervous breakdown retail
if you already know oh this is what it
does there's not a [__] let you off
the hook
this is brilliance brother this is a
different thing as Naomi he's [__]
doing it's just [__] really cool
nice
I'm happy I was around with this table I
would have shot myself I would have shot
myself without even thinking about it
twice
if you're high on acid or something you
listening to
get this dude you're like [__]
worthless I can't write like this oh
yeah yeah this is this is he dragged you
to a [__] party
if I get on the Allman Brothers in and
then after this we don't even even to a
pocket you won't even sleep this is if
they're alright
[Music]
[Laughter]
the doors
listen man this movie fit this into
Apocalypse Now this is brilliant right
date he's got the sword clunky when I go
to watch it
he's got the sword he's got no shirt on
father Grendel's wait
kill me well Atlanta then they show the
Vietnamese killing the cow the cow have
to account breaks in half and they show
Marlon Brando just believes this is
brilliance this is [__] photos this is
complete utter mind [__] this is too
much
[Music]
the doors people
just too much I picked this up
[Music]
before 99 this is you can't do this this
is a [__] this is the [__] I'm not
sure this is the [__] first down he
tucks up is out there but people out
there periscope families go find that
online what's their first stop this up
I'm considering [__] start this start
to lightly hit it you bad mother [__]
the strap on it bad tonight we're gonna
use dream reason to give you a twit Joey
Diaz dotnet slash live but we're gonna
give you a button to press you get the
hats taken out web block plus download
ad block plus go the podcast and come we
could jump up and down with the place of
music
and the podcast will still be up on
YouTube later someone was mad at me and
thought I wasn't gonna put it up on
YouTube as long as it's not like the one
with Dean where there's music throughout
it we're gonna put it up on YouTube so
yeah going up on YouTube cocksuck I
don't believe nobody alright I advise
you [__] go deep on your own
you know I love you dr. 9:15 and given
blood went through looks at my screen
wait till he looks at my [__]
hemoglobin tomorrow my hemoglobins gonna
put that [__] right over the top
oh [__] creepin while you're sleeping
[__] we'll be back in ten minutes
at the podcast a black